there was a really like tragic guitar
solo debacle that happened on live TV
and it did cause me to go into therapy
Nick Jonas gets real about a musical
the reason this all happened the singer
and his brothers Kevin and Joe made an
appearance on the armchair expert with
Dax Shepard podcast where Nick revealed
his most traumatic experience on stage
was at the 2016 ACM Awards alongside
Kelsea ballerini
[Music]
[Applause]
so basically it was during the time that
the brothers were broken up I'm doing
solo stuff I come out for my thing and
again I've rehearsed it a million times
I'm feeling really confident about it
not even really thinking about it like
it's a thing that is going to be
problematic I started off it's fine and
as I sort of walk towards her I just
went completely blank and I hit a wrong
note and like blacked out basically and
clocked that oh my God it was wrong and
I couldn't stop yeah I mean it's
nerve-wracking obviously Nick says the
aftermath of the flub was so intense it
led him to seek professional help and it
did cause me to go into therapy to this
day and like hours of unpacking it I
can't really figure out exactly what
happened yeah but I was like rushed
right into a car and right to a plane
after and I looked at my manager I was
like I think that was bad I was like in
shock kind of yeah and then it was like
a really traumatic moment that shaped
the pressure I put on myself to be
perfect and to always be on it's a lot
of pressure I feel like it is a tough
World
um already
[Music]
that 2016 collab on stage was both Nick
and Kelsey's ACM Awards debut it's my
first ever big award show performance
we're doing two songs and Nick Jonas is
a part of it I think he's so talented I
love his new stuff his solo stuff I mean
he was nice enough to be a part of it
Kelsey's amazing I felt back because I
had an incredibly horrible brain fart
during the show but I'm able to laugh
about now but in the moment it's one of
those things it's a it's every
performance worst nightmare but she was
great about it and and you know separate
to that little moment I think it was a
really unique experience in retrospect I
can kind of like laugh about how big I
thought it was but it did travel more
than I wish it would have Nick seems to
be in a much better place today he and
his Bros got the band back together
big enough
conversations
he got married to Priyanka Chopra who's
like the most romantic one of the two of
you
I I think we we outdo each other yeah we
one-up each other every turn yeah that's
gonna last though we have to like get
realistic about yeah we do no that's
getting here
crazy and last year they welcomed their
first child together a daughter named
malty multi-marie hi Ben
I can't wait to come back here with you
in 15 years and embarrass you in front
of your friends
[Applause]
nothing and you know I think as as
parents it's everything has a new
meaning and has even more meaning and
moments like this uh especially